the samponi is doing nothing it's clear
the ice is already pristine for this
opening nostalgia shot and this driver's
just out for a zam jam joy ride
this is not properly respecting the
power of bonies sweet
can we go ahead and roll commercials
then welcome to the wraparound the
number two used hockey podcast in
southeastern minnesota
naming your youth hockey podcast the
wraparound also pretending to live
podcast
also also children hosting a podcast
more
of the also wearing your cans around
your neck like a dog collar
would you believe there's still yet one
more also this mic placement is terrible
for this environment this audio will be
so full of room noise and echo that will
almost be unlistenable you know
like 95 of podcasts ever produced so
this in
as always is podcasts could we put a pin
in this
i have got to go frazzled single parent
struggles to balance parenting with an
uncaring demanding boss at work cliche
coach t seems to be sporting a new one
calling this a mullet that's like saying
lebron james is overweight
sure it's technically true according to
some sort of accepted scientific formula
but one look and you know that's some
technicality bullsh
now for anyone who's new to the show or
earth
the docs are a powerhouse organization
expositional podcasting
export position having a pavilion built
for one youth hockey team
minnesota may need an intervention i
truly hate how disney titles stuff
are we supposed to say this title disney
the mighty ducks
game changers under this theory youtube
should have gone with google the karate
kid cobra kais
just call the show game changers or the
quack is back or
the mighty and the meek but stop it with
all the branding nostalgia baiting
nonsense
of course it could just be i'm still mad
they didn't call the sequel to the movie
duck duck deuce when it was right there
in front of their faces
all day long hockey dads you're not
super tight or anything but him and his
mom
have often been our non-jewish guests at
passover that's racist
actually that's quite nice and very
inclusive hmm this is really awkward
sure what to do now look a werewolf this
run to the net has over a dozen cuts in
the span of 10 seconds
is marvel editing the hockey in the show
too i promise i'll get faster
maybe you will but it won't be on the
ducks
i gotta cut you cutting a player
publicly even the pros do it in closed
offices
have you even seen moneyball bro you
know
i i never bought into any of this
craziness mom stands up for her son with
a big speech that ends up not helping
and
embarrasses him cliche honestly there's
going to be a lot of sports and
parenting cliches in this so let's just
add five cents to the penalty box and
move on
i'm not a trainer i'm a pediatric sports
psychologist among the bevy of humans
going against human nature and
unnecessarily making public fools of
themselves in this scene mr psp here is
the worst
why would he even pipe in here is he
offended at an absolutely minuscule
distinction does he think this moment is
about him somehow does he see the world
as a constant excuse to get his opinions
out even if it's only tangentially
related i guess this is just a long way
of saying
twitter bringing a carafe to refill your
water instead of a water bottle and
setting that open container next to
all your electronics and that's all for
tonight on the wraparound
so you just had five minutes of silence
on your podcast because there is zero
chance you picked up any of parenthood's
rant
so she sits under the minnesota moon
wondering
what lies ahead she'll contain
surprisingly few minnesota accents or
mentions of hot dishes don't you know
any chance for a follow-up interview uh
i don't think so
great i'm headed over kids he's so upset
he won't come out of his room confiding
to a random child about your parenting
fails
i would not be an acid physically i have
more
of a podcast body that's miist
also potbot is the new dad bod spread
the word not only do we have the kids
congregating outside of school
establishing shot cliche happening here
it's in minnesota during the winter
the only way these kids are congregating
by this tree before school is if they
froze there overnight
riding a skateboard in the hallway sorry
my
school monitor comes out sometimes i
think it gets a little scary i noticed
you enjoy flaming your body into large
objects
title of my sex tape wearing a prove you
aren't a robot by identifying which
pictures contain traffic lights t-shirt
not a rose guy says the guy who
literally just followed the never turn
down a dare rule
make up your mind mr peer pressure
anarchist i know
you're all popular and winners in the
game of life whoa
this cool fresh idea of using the school
cafeteria to represent cliques and poor
social behavior is blowing my mind
why has no one ever done this before
they make fun of me because i dress like
a warrior princess and go to magic the
gathering conventions
warrior princesses and magic the
gathering i think this show forgot it
doesn't take place in the 90s with the
movies
the mighty mean girls look five tater
tots
not even a full order dear god 25 sins
you monsters
dude he just said he was bummed about
not having enough tots and you snag one
without even asking
are we supposed to like this kid because
that ship just sailed out of
top thief bastard harbor i can't get
past this goalie who is he
honestly kid it doesn't even matter that
shot was wide right anyway so maybe take
an actual shot on goal before you start
complaining too much
allowing a child's real name on an
online gaming platform
we're almost there stalking is it me or
does it feel like we're about to enter
the house from
it i'm getting more of a monster house
vibe than it but
sure continue on with your mega basic
pop ref show
you see things dude before and better
than anyone while i'm aware that video
games can have actual cognitive benefits
there's no indication that training
yourself for 10 000 hours how to push a
series of buttons based on small visual
cues would in any way develop
full arm and hand reflexes finger
dexterity and coordination has its
benefits in many ways but let's just say
they aren't usually practiced in a
hockey rink
i said usually and that is what makes
you special
yeah but they don't have to wear pants
coop 13 would be mighty at tv sins
i need you to go down there hand out
these brochures
plus i know you just ran out of hockey
rink options and there's one you can
stumble onto right across the street
from there that will really help move
the plot along
so why wouldn't this be in whatever
directory alex was looking up the other
local rinks in we see shortly they throw
birthday parties and whatnot
how do those people get in touch with
the ice palace how much are we talking
about
someone please enlighten me as to the
reason she would rather take the time to
write this number down and slide it to
him instead of just
saying it out loud i'm waiting i'm
actually not waiting
whatever you came up with is cheap and
wrong and dumb
and you should be ashamed for even
trying congratulations it's an exciting
time to be alive
i'll get the paperwork i don't know if
i'm just glad to have emilio estevez in
my life or what but this show is growing
on me and i'm about to give it a sin off
before this nostalgia based stupor wears
off
here's the long and short of it i hate
hockey and i don't like kids but i still
manage an ice rink which is usually
ground zero for both
as opposed to taking any other job
whatsoever as one does
yeah i've been known to slap the biscuit
around a bit
slapping the biscuit you know we have
our first hockey practice tonight you
should come by we'll see you on the ice
but we're not going to tell you where it
is or what time or check with your
parents because i'm sure none of that is
important
i mean technically obviously he has a
dad but
[Music]
using the hot chocolate machine is the
skip button i'm not saying it because
it's wrong i'm sitting it because i'm
jealous i don't have one
i probably should have mentioned i
actually suck and i waited to tell you
this till now because the person that
wrote the script is overly reliant on
the withholding information from the
audience to use as a surprise later
routine
wasting perfectly mediocre cafeteria
food when you could have just dropped
the empty tray instead
thing is everything she said in that
video was true
i used to be a mighty duck
[Music]
is there anyone who understands a little
bit of what i'm trying to say
i am duckicus i can't believe you put a
team together
and i can't believe you're just now
having this conversation oh wait
who's gonna be your coach considering
alex said she would find the coach why
is she laying this question on evan
the name for your team the don't bothers
the don't bothers the don't bothers
that's so terrible you might as well
have named them the mighty grow goose
just to remind you all the 12 to 14 year
old division is full
contact not if you want to be in an
official u.s youth hockey league
they raised the minimum age for checking
to 13 a while back
still not sure what makes a 13 year old
concussion better than a 12 year old one
but either way you're wrong i as you say
in hockey
checked this is the real deal oh
crap what the puck why is evan surprised
about the full contact announcement
even if the other kids on the team
didn't know he would have since he was
practicing with the ducks prior to this
and he should have let his teammates
know is evan the villain in this show
this greatest love of all's on for some
time
two minutes by yourself and you feel
shame
hey uh what's up dan we have sort of a
problem here
yeah you apparently didn't put one of
the new cover sheets on your tps reports
yeah maybe it's the half cycle buddy i
know what you mean maybe we should rip a
full cycle buddy
full cycle buddy you're telling my son
don't bother
you don't bother sir how dare you sir
the king's stuck in this game you should
play another team
i took the kings to the cub yeah against
the computer with the offsides
they're a finesse team is it me or does
it feel like we're about to enter the
house from
it means how you want to spend your
summer inside of an arcade
you'd spending it inside of your mother
if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball isn't that kind of
um that's the word i'm looking for evil
like it's the fruits of the devil
the cream i was about to make an ice
cream sundae
you want one hello everyone my name is
evan
a few of you may know me from such
nature films as earwigs ooh
and man vs nature the road to victory
because now i'm starting a new team just
me nick and logan tonight we skate with
them
tonight we stay with them